this is Startalk bill neil do you still
have your house in California yes Studio
City yes I've been there yes you're like
a native New Yorker now not native but
you would live in the or somebody else
is living in your house yeah that's a
crazy house that you live in it's cool
it's completely alive with
self-generated electricity it's got four
watts of soar that's great
which is more than enough for ten months
of the year maybe ten and a half months
of the year mm-hmm and I would have more
but my neighbor's house shadows my
panels oh I thought you're gonna say
your neighbor stealing your electricity
she's stealing same travels a lot and I
thought maybe while she was out of town
I could just cut off just like this one
part of the second story mm-hmm easier
to ask forgiveness than permission
I'll get rebuilt but well yeah sorry
there's tons of oil still in reserve ah
that is yet to be drilled or here's the
bad news okay but we'll never run out of
fossil fuels oh that is the bad news
that's terrible it really is because
burning it and burning it is just the
worst thing for all of us the plan
what's your plan so the plan is because
as long as our oil is cheap and it's
cheaper than my solar panels how do you
expect people to so if you're rich you
can you can buy the car that saves bear
in mind the reason it cost you more than
the car that doesn't say well but it's
on wheels the cement wheels got reason
you want a sex on wheels electric car
costing how much yeah everybody's got
heard of that breath yeah yeah - my
mattress deep breath it's 95% efficient
or 93 percent efficient whereas a gas
powered car constrained by the second
law of thermodynamics is at best twenty
eight percent thirty percent so you're
squandering energy you just can't get
back when you try to get it out of heat
at low temperature differences so with
that said there is it's been estimated
that we could save about 30% of the
energy we use through conservation
we can have electric cars we can improve
transportation systems to be sure this
is Startalk